[Music]
well george everybody's talking about
the fed raising
the fed rate uh 75 basis points three
quarters of a percent
of interest and the fed of course did
this to stop inflation
it's a slow inflation
this is weird
okay i don't know understand
well i do understand because it's
political crap but
here's the thing okay if inflation is
caused by and there have been times in
our history where the economy just gets
booming
and just the economy is just on
fire it's just burning white hot and if
inflation is caused by that a rise in
interest rates will slow inflation
the inflation that we're currently
experiencing was not caused by that
it was caused by gas prices going
through the roof because biden stopped
domestic oil production
because he's trying to be a greenie
it's a problem
inflation in this case is caused by
biden bucks causing paying people to not
work consequently they didn't work
consequently the ones that were working
charge more so it takes a 30 or 25 an
hour person to put bread on the shelves
now and you used to pay them 10 an hour
and by the way the price of bread
reflects the cost of labor
so the disrupted labor market by
government's interference caused this
inflation oh we had a supply chain
disruption because of pandemic
this caused this inflation none of those
things are affected by interest rates
raising interest rates by the fed did
absolutely nothing to stop this set of
inflation so do it more they said well
they're they're at the wrong party and
they came late
i mean that's the idiots you're saying
we got energy labor and supply chain are
the real problems and none of those are
impacted by interest rates none of them
none i mean you know the gas prices are
not the result of interest rates
they're not
the white hot economy was there wasn't
it was white hot in places i mean we had
real estate booming we had some other
stuff shortages and stuff but the supply
chain disruption was running labor
lumber prices up lumber's back down 33
this month
so you get ready to build a house it's
33 cheaper on lumber than it was this
time last year
okay so
the inflation is correcting itself and
yet the fed raises interest rates but
everybody's panicking and freaking out
about this the great news is is that it
doesn't do much of anything except
probably further drive us into a
recession because this is slowing the
economy down they're slowing the economy
down which was already slowing down and
heading into a recession
so we're getting ready to have something
fairly unusual which is inflation during
a recession
that's a fairly unusual economic thing
because usually the two are somewhat
connected in this case because
the the speed or the velocity of the
economy was not the cause of the
inflation you can actually have
inflation caused by
you know a
horrible
domestic
fuel price policy or fuel supply policy
right so biden is straight up causing
that that sticker at the pump i did that
yeah he absolutely did that okay he did
not cause the supply chain disruption
it's not his fault the republicans are
going to blame him for it because they
want to get everybody that has a d in
front of their name out in the fall but
he didn't do that it's not his fault
okay because he does he can't control
supply chain the president doesn't have
that but he can influence the fed and
the fed apparently is dumber than a rock
of course we kind of knew some of these
things because they really they used the
wrong tool they came to the wrong party
and they were late
so what is the solution if you're if
you're the fed what's your move just sit
the best thing you can do in a
capitalistic economy is let it correct
itself
it'll it'll heal itself faster because
it's people acting in their own best
self-interest
and it'll heal itself faster if you let
it run its course let these supply chain
things run out
do anything you can with policy or with
regulations to
smooth it so that they can the stuff can
get on out of the ports and get in
people's stores again that's what caused
it right so the government screwed that
up you know you got billions of goods
sitting on the seas
in the uh you know
in the port at la billions of dollars
sitting there for months
and that's all just stupid butt
government regulations it's all that is
and so if you you can smooth that out
but you can't fix that you have to let
it fix itself the labor market if you
hadn't been throwing money at people
begging them to vote for you then then
you wouldn't have had the labor market
disruption
it would have just it would have but
it'll it'll straighten itself out if you
quit throwing money at it and they have
quit i think for now throwing money at
it so it all would be okay but they've
just exasperated everything there's a
vicious cycle there because as things
get more expensive you got to pay people
more in order to afford it and so it
and so what's happening is now
with the economy slowing down with a
recession it is receding two quarters in
a row of the gross domestic product
which is the measure of all goods and
services the gdp
two consecutive quarters of it being
smaller is the definition of a recession
so the economy's slowing down
and guess what happens
those companies
they're not selling as much that's the
definition of an economy slowing down
and guess what happens when they don't
sell as much they start laying people
off and guess what happens they don't
have as much profit and so wall street
looks over there and goes you're not as
profitable and stocks down 20 since the
first year now we got a bear market to
add to this mess
and it's all cause these dubers won't
keep their fingers out of the pie
just back off bozo
let the thing do its thing
that's all you got to do the economy
isn't a magical thing because it's a
bunch of individuals all acting in their
own best self-interest
long-term and short-term and people have
generally pretty good thoughts out there
so
the rays of the fed what's it do uh it's
the cost that one bank loans money to
another bank it's the interest rate
so the interest that banks charge is
going to go up
oh wait a minute credit cards didn't go
up because it was already 18 percent
how many they're not going to raise it
to 18 and three quarter okay so what is
going to go up
car loans
they'll be more expensive student loan
which is interest rates could go up
if you if you if you're currently
sitting with if you're not going to go
borrow money
on
something other than a credit if you've
got a student loan it's fixed if you got
a mortgage it's fixed even if you got a
car loan it's fixed but if you're going
to go buy a new car it's probably going
to be a higher interest rate
a month from now than it would have been
four months ago and if you've got an
offer but we would have told you not to
do that anyway stupid you don't borrow
money on a car you pay cash for it okay
so it doesn't affect ramsey listeners
because you don't have credit cards you
bet you're paying off the debt that
you've got you're not going to go to a
bank and borrow money the fed rate does
not cause mortgage rates
mortgage rates are caused by the bond
market now it influences it we like
relationship there typically mortgage
rates follow the fed rate but it
mechanically is not connected it's
simply what banks loan to another bank
it's the wholesale cost of money between
two banks
and so it doesn't cause mortgage rates
mortgages are packaged together and sold
on the bond market so whatever the bond
market is doing is what drives mortgage
rates but it usually follows it and
guess what a bear market
stocks going down generally what happens
to bonds they go up
so that's going to actually help maybe
offset it
it's a very complicated thing thank you
for that
the point is none of you need to panic
just sit back and watch the circus well
what's fun about not mine
you know just sit back and watch the
circus you know i'm not in let's get
popcorn while we're at it i'm not going
to participate in your all's craziness
i'm going to watch you all it's great
don't do it you see your guys are going
to be okay turn off the news because
they're going to cause you to panic
they're peddling fear porn this is the
ramsey show